350 ans il aura fallu plus de trois
siècles pour que la vision de Lenôtre se
réalise dans le parc du château de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le bassin de 50
mètres de diamètre le plus grand deal de
France apporte la touche finale au grand
ensemble imaginé par le jardinier Royal
[Musique]
alors il y a des débats là-dessus on
sait qu'il a existé sur les plans on
sait que le nôtre le voulait on pense
qu'il a existé mais il y a sans doute eu
dès le départ des problèmes d'adduction
d'eau on n'a pas réussi à l'alimenter en
eau et évidemment un bassin qui n'a pas
d'eau en plus un bassin aussi important
ça peut pas durer éternellement donc il
a progressivement disparu un bassin
oublié est des jardins disparu au fil du
temps le départ de Louis XIV pour
Versailles avait laissé le temps faire
son ouvrage jusqu'à ce jour de 2020 où
la ville de Saint-Germain est la
Fondation du Patrimoine décide de lancer
une souscription parce que l'État a dit
c'est que on se consacrait nous état à
l'entretien du château mais si les
collectivités territoriale trouver les
crédits pour restaurer le grand bassin
on y serait favorable et on
accompagnerait et c'est ce qui s'est
produit et c'est ça qui est merveilleux
coût total plus de 6 millions et demi
d'euros mais la réalisation de ce bassin
qui s'ajoute à deux autres de plus
petites tailles est aussi et avant tout
une prouesse technique un mètre plus bas
seulement se trouve les couloirs de la
gare adjacente une contrainte technique
surmontée en près de deux ans pour
permettre de donner enfin au parc sa
perspective finale
[Musique]
pour avoir un point focal dans une
perspective il faut avoir un objet à
regarder et ici l'objet c'est le jet
d'eau
et donc ce point focal est placé à un
endroit qui est la convergence de tous
les regards vers l'horizon et au-delà
des aspects esthétiques et symboliques
la finalisation du grand parterre est
aussi l'occasion d'établir un nouveau
trait d'union entre la ville et les
jardins
[Musique]